while protesters in Iraq have gathered
near the Danish Embassy in Baghdad
angered by another incident of Quran
burning this time in Copenhagen these
rallies are happening after the Swedish
Embassy in that same city was stormed on
Thursday you're watching live pictures
now from Baghdad you were caught last
month an Iraqi Refugee who is a former
militia member burned the Quran during a
protest in Stockholm triggering outrage
around the world well let's speak to our
correspondent on the ground
joins us from Baghdad muff but you're
not far from the embassy what have you
been seeing
well we have been seeing hundreds of
angry protesters they gathered here
coming from the capital Baghdad and from
other provinces as well chanting against
the desecration of the Holy Quran and
they are telling us that they're here
today raising raising copies of the Holy
Quran and of the Iraqi flag to express
their rejection of the desecration of
the Holy Quran and the Iraqi flag three
times in less than a month in both two
times in Sweden and one time in
Copenhagen if I can just move out of the
frame so that you can get a bigger
picture of what's Happening Here as you
can see right behind me the raising the
Iraqi flags and copies of the Holy Quran
they also this place is not far from the
fence of the green zone remember that
last night they tried to storm the green
zone to reach the Danish and following
the desecration of the Holy Quran the
burning of the Iraqi flag in front of
the Iraqi Embassy in Copenhagen as you
know that these protesters have been
also calling on the International
Community to draft laws to to draft laws
to prevent the aggression the
desecration of the Holy books
mother attacks or protests targeting two
foreign embassies now that's becoming a
security challenge surely for the Iraqi
authorities there
[Music]
well Iraqi security forces have been
striving to prevent them last night from
reaching the Danish Embassy inside the
heavily fortified green zone remember
this is this is very close to defense of
the the green zone so the do you want to
say that they're sending a message from
here next to the green zone that they
are they are they can reach the Danish
Embassy and they're threatening to take
matters into their own hands remember
today in the southern city of Basra
angry protesters set fire on Caravan
Caravans belonging to a Danish company
in the southern city of
meanwhile the government has been
working on different uh directions it
has sent a message today addressing the
organization of Islamic cooperation
expressing its desire to draft laws to
prevent islamophobia and to prevent the
hate speech the government it has been
calling on the Islamic Organization
for cooperation to
hold an emergency meeting to face the
islamophobia and the desecration of holy
books but meanwhile the government has
also issued a statement namely the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs assuring
foreign
embassies that the government is
committed to protect diplomatic missions
by virtue of the Geneva conventions
which regulates the Diplomatic ties
between countries and I see now as well
Iran's foreign Ministry has summoned the
Danish Ambassador there to protest
against the desecration of the Quran and
Copenhagen to Mahmoud Abdullah on the
ground there for us at those protests in
Baghdad thank you